This is Station four take four side.
And the second time you are talking about the bank and the restrictions that are placed on people.
Now these men were most of them.
Kind films and had moved to the to eat and valuable part comfortable I had their own banana farms or market gardens
and I saw there is stuff.
And there is money in all the money went into work in the bank the savings bank as it was and then. Well.
They were in town. One day and I thought they did. That in the States the banks are all closed.
So I thought I'd go to the banker or get a money help this Friday.
And there must be in about twenty of them went to the bank when I got there the door's closed.
So they say to each other. Being there but his power.
You gotta get him Tom I hope we knock on this one from the back door. Yeah.
Give me that my own food I break in this glass window. That man I was money well. This went on home owning.
I'm a local cops came and said.
You can't go on like this and I turned on the course and I said that one problem bank of money blow. You.
We wanted that money.
Well this went on
and family who would police at the police call the bank manager the arm through the window to open up
and let them have their money but these were the things that were happening and.
It was I realize now
but I realized how distressed the older people were to think that the bank that I had so much faith
and trust that looked after the humanity that gave him a bit of interest
and made them feel secure was no longer there really was no longer the.
Depression stuff just before we played the depression would you like to say what your first job was what you actually
did when you decided to leave school and start working. Well first of all I. I got a job immediately or left school.
Which was a very unusual thing in the depths of the Depression and that was with first class. And I learnt a lot from.
The whole Tom. Like a couple of afternoons who we choose a very lovely person.
She had a thriving business even in the Depression because what she made was so beautiful
and there were still people with money handful or they were.
So I would watch her and she teach me how to be the clothes and be beaten.
She was just really good to me then one day she said. If you want to a few more.
Women up the hill like you to do some work and if it's raining money because people couldn't get a job anywhere.
And so I ended up working for this woman I'd leave him at six in the morning walk the mile and a half or two
or whatever it was get there in the morning go down and pick up the meat for breakfast for her boarders
and come back and help her to cook the breakfast for them. And when they'd all gone.
Then I'd wash up all the issues with her. And. And that went on for two three years. Those two chair opposite.
It went on until the war or close to the war because once the war once was and I would cook
and that's what I learned to do a lot of cooking in actual fact good plain stuff you know because my mother didn't
teach me a thing not to think she couldn't be bothered if she couldn't do it so she wouldn't bother verite.
So I had like sponge cakes I think of that today. You know I could turn a sponge cake out of a few.
Declared you know one hundred thirty nine in September. And it was it happened overnight. Let the good jobs everywhere.
The men were enlisting. And they were whatever jobs they had women were moving in to take them. So. Some.
One once said Well if it didn't do it took the loss of many people. It took a lot of lives to end a depression.
And that was in fact what happened because the world the manufacturing of ammunition
and particularly ply all that of war ships and it required people to do that and that worked better in the Depression.
OK.